das ist eine wirklich rätselhafte
entdeckung die einem amerikanischen
forschungsteam jetzt mit dem mini boden
detector gelungen ist die rede ist von
einem deutlichen überschuss von
elektronen neutrinos ein phänomen das so
nicht mit dem standardmodell der
teilchenphysik zu erklären ist doch was
steckt hinter diesen verräterischen
abweichung handelt es sich vielleicht um
eine vierte worte einen neutrinos die
bislang nur theoretisch vorhergesagt
worden war
oder steckt etwa sogar die dunkle
materie hinter dieser mysteriöse
entdeckung alles was wir bislang zu der
spektakulären meldung wissen erfahrt ihr
jetzt bei pixum science fiction hier
gibt es täglich faszinierendes 1 videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
neutrinos über diese elementarteilchen
kann man gar nicht genug reden sie sind
die häufigsten elementarteilchen
überhaupt denn sie formen galaxien und
bewegen das universum sie sind
elektrisch neutral leicht und vor allem
eins mysteriös oft werden sie auch als
geister teilchen bezeichnet denn anstatt
mit materie zu interagieren rasen sie
beispielsweise durch planeten bäume oder
häuser einfach so hindurch durch unseren
körper strömt in jeder sekunde
milliarden neutrinos ohne dass wir es
überhaupt bemerken mittlerweile wissen
wir dass drei sorten von ihnen
existieren elektron myon und tau
neutrinos diese drei sorten geister
teilchen können sich im flug ineinander
umwandeln
in der fachsprache heißt das sie
oszillieren
das ist auch der grund warum die
elektron neutrinos die von der sonne
ausgesendet werden nur zum teil als
solche in unseren detektoren auf der
erde ankommen
die anderen elektron neutrinos haben auf
ihrem weg zu uns den typ gewechselt doch
diese 3 neutrino sorten sind vielleicht
nicht alles schon in den 90er jahren gab
es erste indizien dafür dass es
vielleicht eine weitere viertel
neutrinos orte geben könnte messdaten
eines amerikanischen detektors lieferten
hinweise darauf dass neben den drei
bereits bekannten neutrinos auch noch
die sogenannten sterilen neutrinos
existieren könnten dieses physikalische
experiment ist unter dem begriff msn.de
bekannt da steht für liquid sinti later
neutrino detektor also in etwa so viel
wie flüssig
senator neutrino detector einige
fachleute erklärten die messergebnisse
des msn de experiments mit der existenz
eben dieser vierten neutrinos und doch
bis heute ist diese interpretation
umstritten und eine große schwierigkeit
die existenz der vierten neutrino worte
endgültig zu beweisen liegt daran dass
sie der theorie nach überhaupt gar nicht
mit materie wechselwirken gar nicht doch
dafür beeinflussten sie die oszillation
der anderen drei neutrino sorten so
zumindest die gängige annahme mit ihrer
existenz könnten sogar einige bisher
unerklärliche phänomene verstanden
werden angefangen bei der asymmetrie von
materie und antimaterie bis hin zu den
teilchen der dunklen materie besonders
außergewöhnlich ist auch dass die
existenz der sterilen neutrinos einfach
nicht mit dem standardmodell der
teilchenphysik in einklang gebracht
werden kann umso sensationeller also die
entdeckung des forschungsteams vom
fermilab die mithilfe des neutrino
detektors mini boom gelang bei diesem
experiment wird ein aus hauptsächlich
million neutrinos bestehen das strahlt
auf einen detektor gerichtet in einem
tank mit flüssigem mineralölwirtschaft
welche teilchen bei kollisionen der
neutrinos mit atomen entstehen aus
diesen ergebnissen kann dann abgeleitet
werden welche neutrino sorten den
detektor erreicht haben dazu richard van
de water einer der beteiligten forscher
wir können zwar nicht mit sicherheit
sagen dass es sich um sterile neutrinos
handelt aber hier steht definitiv etwas
fundamentales vorsicht die aktuelle
erfolgsmeldung basiert auf der
auswertung der testdaten aus den letzten
15 jahren
denn fest steht hier kamen deutlich mehr
elektro neutrinos am detektor an als es
das gängige standardmodell der
teilchenphysik erlauben würde
das mini boden experiment erreicht in
sachen elektronen neutrino überschuss
eine signifikanz von 4,7 sigma das ist
ein maß ja der verlässlichkeit sechs
sigma sind es sogar wenn die ergebnisse
des snb detektors also der experimente
aus den 90er jahren
zum besseren verständnis eine
signifikanz von mehr als 5 sigma werden
in der teilchenphysik als klarer hinweis
auf eine entdeckung gewertet messfehler
hält das us forschungsteam für fast
ausgeschlossen
der gleiche effekt ist nun in zwei
verschiedenen experimenten beobachtet
worden
das macht es eher unwahrscheinlich dass
bei beiden der gleiche fehler
aufgetreten sein soll
fest steht hier wird etwas beobachtet
das absolut spannend ist denn eigentlich
sollte es so nicht sein
die beobachteten anomalien widersprechen
ganz eindeutig dem standardmodell der
teilchenphysik dennoch ist es kein
hundertprozentiger beweis für die steril
neutrinos die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler schließen auch eine
andere ebenfalls super spannende
erklärung nicht aus denn das ergebnis
könnte beispielsweise auch durch eine
bislang noch unbekannte wechselwirkung
von neutrinos mit dunkler materie
erklärt werden der physiker joachim kopp
von der universität mainz war an diesem
experiment nicht beteiligt doch auch er
ist wie die meisten seiner kolleginnen
und kollegen schwer von dieser
entdeckung begeistert denn es besteht
die chance dass diese neutrino
oszillation das lange gesuchte fenster
in eine neue physik sind die uns helfen
wird die menge des standardmodells zu
beheben
durch die analyse von großen datenmengen
gelangen wir zu immer mehr
bahnbrechenden erkenntnissen und dabei
wird auch immer öfter künstliche
intelligenz ki eingesetzt ist die ki die
letzte erfindung der menschheit das
video dazu gibt es hier unbedingt drauf
klicken und natürlich auch raumzeit
block der zukunft abonnieren sehr sehr
cooler kanal bis dann bleibt dran